all right guys
bang bang got a very special treat will
is here as always to cover on chain
metrics but we also have checkmate who
works at glass node
um so we got a whole bunch of great
stuff for you uh will maybe let's start
with you real quick
uh give us a summary of what you've seen
in the on-chain metrics for uh for this
past week
yeah so hey pomp and checkmate i'm super
excited to do this
um you know from from my newsletter just
kind of from a very high level overview
some of the things i saw this week where
you know first of all obviously
we're still trading in this you know 32
to 40k range
um a little over um you know 15 of
bitcoin's money supply has now moved in
this range so we're kind of building up
this
pretty large base of capital here uh
hash rate has continued to trend down
um you know at one point it dipped down
to the lowest point it's been since late
2019
so of course block intervals are you
know a little
larger than that traditional 10-minute
time frame
at one point they got over 23 minutes
which
of course it means that issuance has
slowed but on the bright side the
difficulty adjustment should be coming
in the next few days i think on sunday
people are projecting it to be and
miners are slightly selling
and but you know in in the glasgow data
it doesn't appear that it's anything
substantial right this
has been a big narrative that miners
have been dumping and that's what been
what's been really driving the price but
in the data that at least i'm looking at
it doesn't appear that way younger coins
continue to sell
generally but this week we had the
largest day
of net realized losses in bitcoin's
history in dollar terms which i think is
important because
we've had other very large capitulation
events
but you know obviously in the the larger
bitcoin gross you know in dollar terms
these events are going to be larger so
still no major uptick in wales this is
something we've kind of been tracking
uh you know watching for new whales
coming on the network
at the same time retail has been adding
aggressively
you know over the last two three weeks
especially uh it seems like
the smaller cohorts um you know the
shrimp uh as
glasnode likes to label them under one
btc they continue to add aggressively to
their holdings
and just in general uh you know the kind
of re-accumulation continues
and uh exchange flows are kind of
sideways to bullish
so um you know nothing crazy in terms of
those things just kind of continuation
of what we've been following over the
last two weeks
awesome and check me maybe you can
introduce yourself a little bit um
and talk about kind of what you do on a
day-to-day basis before we get into the
more of the on-chain metrics
absolutely so thanks for having on here
uh so my student name is checkmate and
i've
started working with glassnode as
non-chain analysts and
really what what my role has been there
and what continues to be
is really the education side so
everything from writing
our weekly newsletter the week on chain
uh we're also pushing out various other
you know content lines just really
trying to
explain and get more people to
understand what the value of on-chain is
so
it's one of these i mean it's a brand
new discipline it's really only existed
since 2018 but
ultimately that was the you know the
original metrics and it's taken time for
people to really digest
uh the information that we can pull from
on chain and it's uh it's really about
getting more people to understand
how valuable uh the data really is and
you know like anything it's a tool and
it can be used rightly and wrongly but
it's really about trying to build that
uh the education base so
you know on-chain is one of these tools
that retail has access to
at the same time as hedge funds right
very much in the open source ethos
uh this whole market where you know
everybody has equal access and people
who are willing to study and
take the time to learn about it can can
get outside advantage
got it and so when you wake up every
morning and you look at the on-chain
metrics like what are the two or three
metrics that you really look at that you
say hey this gives me a quick
overview of uh kind of what's going on
or the things that you find kind of the
highest signal
so there's probably three key areas that
i'll look at the first one is just based
on
almost the immediate term on chain
activity right are we seeing a whole lot
of
uh value being settled are we seeing
upticks and active addresses the really
simple stuff that
you know it's quite intuitive are you
seeing more people using the network
when more people are using it
it generally suggests that there's some
value being settled and people are
finding uh finding use in it
and you know as you would expect during
bearish markets that really starts to
taper off during bullish markets it
picks up so
it gives you a more immediate uh signal
um what i'll also look at is the split
between spending behavior of old and
young coins
so really this is what we classify
lifespan metrics so what i really care
about is are the old
people have held their coins for two
years three years people who bought in
last cycle
are they essentially offloading and
conversely if they're not offloading
then
you know i'm in a hazardous guess that
they're more likely to be accumulating
than selling so
looking at the overall spent age how old
the coins are that are on the move
that's a that's a big element and
there's a lot of different layers to
that
so there's nuance in the different
metrics you can look at
and then the last one they'll look at is
supply based metrics so
you know we at glass note we've got
everything from long term short term
holders miners
different addresses i'll really look at
the the overall supply dynamics
uh are we in a space where you know more
coins are accumulating are we in a space
where coins are coming into exchange
so really looking at that on chain
supply and demand and how those coins
are flowing around the system
got it and so when uh you look at kind
of where we've been over the last few
weeks uh will and i have been covering
on a week-to-week basis you know kind of
this sidewards
uh uh sideways accumulation um are you
seeing anything specific in the on-chain
metrics that you think people should uh
should understand or anything that kind
of sticks out to you as uh
surprising um or rather insightful
compared to
maybe what people would see on the
surface sure so yeah i mean what we
really saw uh over this computer it's
been it's been quite interesting because
there's a number of
dynamics at play we had our initial
capitulation back there at start of may
uh which you know by all intents uh lev
i think it was the largest dollar value
as well mentioned
um in terms of total realized losses it
really was a fairly you know it's a
capitulation for the ages right it sits
back and compares to
march 2020 and and you know the end of
the 2018 bear
in pretty much all metrics so there was
there was an extraordinary amount of
supply that solid
loss in that first capitulation phase
we've then essentially absorbed i mean
we've been chopping around down here in
the 35 to 29 k
range for you know almost two months now
and we had a second capitulation last
week as it tried to sell off down to 28
and what was really interesting about
that is that the market absorbed it
right so we had there is an enormous
flaw down here at 30 000
um because it absorbed that uh second
capitulation which
i don't believe i've seen elsewhere the
you know two back-to-back capitulation
events
um both over three billion in total uh
net volume
and simultaneously we've got this giant
uh the great
migration of hash power coming out of
china and as will mentioned
you know there are going to be miners
who have to liquidate parts of their
treasury and
you know they're just dealing with
immense logistical costs at the moment
so there is going to be a layer of that
uh but simultaneously when you compare
there's two elements um is that supply
being absorbed and well we held the 29th
floor multiple times so far so
you know to be honest i'm surprised we
haven't gone lower and that's a sign of
strength as far as i'm concerned
and uh you know meanwhile once this
difficulty adjusts down
uh tomorrow we're going to see all of
the miners who are still on the network
become immensely more profitable they're
mining at the same hash per dollar
um so their expenses are more or less
the same as what they were
uh prior but most of their competition
you know 50
of their competition has now turned off
their machine so those coins are going
to get shared
almost two times to uh all of the miners
that remain on the network so
for every miner that's selling their
treasury there's gonna be another miner
who's essentially selling a
extraordinary amount less coins because
their expenses are the same but their
inflows are much higher
so we're gonna have some really
interesting supply dynamics in play but
uh
you know the market's absorbed a lot so
far which is quite impressive
so so check you know do you kind of look
at this as
you know a lot of supply got puked out
you know when you look at you know
liquid supply chains and you just see
this
huge drawdown right um a lot of supply
became liquid
and during that big capitulation event
and now it's just kind of
this process of we're kind of chopping
sideways bearish
um as those coins are kind of
reaccumulated by and absorbed by
you know strong hands so i you know
i think one way to kind of analogize
this is like a bunch of
liquid like no pun intended got spilled
out on the counter right and so
slowly you're kind of like adding more
paper towels to absorb the spill and
it's a matter of like as long as we
don't have any more
liquid coins you know spilling out onto
the counter
and as long as that doesn't happen you
know over time
the paper towels are going to absorb
absorb the spill but it
it's just a matter of you know how how
long is it going to take i guess and
um you know can can that kind of outpace
the the reabsorption can that
outpace um the rate that you know if we
have any kind of second kind of liquid
supply change where where
you know coins get puked out and and you
see a bunch more of the supply come on
exactly and you know what i'm really
seeing at the moment is uh pretty much
the there's there's two sides so the old
hands people have held their coins for a
long period of time we have this very
interesting
dynamic at the moment so at glasgow
we've got a long term holder short-term
holder and
um for for ease of access there is a
curve over which they uh they actually
mature but
we look at about five months roughly 155
days is kind of the median time you know
plus or minus a few days
either side to smooth out the data but
really what we look at there is
if you look back five months we were
roughly at the same price
and prior to that five months we were
rallying up into you know 42 000. so
we have this very interesting dichotomy
where pretty much all long-term holders
are profitable
and pretty much all short-term holders
aside from the people who bought the 29
000 dip
are essentially at a loss so when we're
seeing losses get realized on chain it's
disproportionately the day-to-day
traffic because they're people who
essentially bought their coins in in
recent history
um they may not have dealt with that
kind of volatility so
there's a number of things that i'm
watching um one is the coins that were
purchased in january february because
that was obviously a fairly heated time
in the market
and very very shortly we're going to be
moving so that five month barrier
is going to be underwater all right so
we're going to start seeing coins that
were bought just after
tesla invested you know that whole hype
phase we're going to see them start
moving underwater and the question is
are they
going to become liquid supply right are
they going to start distributing back
into the market
what we've seen so far is that that
hasn't happened as i mentioned
almost all of our lifespan metrics have
just i mean quite honestly they've
collapsed so we've seen
very very little spending going on by by
the old hands
um now the question is do we get a
relief rally and
and they basically take that exit
liquidity that would be something that
i'd be paying attention to so lifespan
metrics particularly on any kind of
strong relief rally is something i'm
going to be watching
um but one thing that does give me a bit
of confidence is we saw that
you know that capitulation the other day
uh that sold off down to 29
and we saw almost no long-term hold of
spending at that point in time it was
very
i mean there was a couple in there
obviously but really is a
disproportionate
number of short-term holders and then we
bounced so what that told me is that the
market absorbed that supply and if the
long-term holders are you know if
they're not
accumulating at this point in time then
i'll be watching for that relief rally
and see what the behavior is at that
point
yeah i looked at um short-term holder
sober and i mean it just
dropped like a rock it was pretty wild
but then to see you know it bounced
um you know the next day or two was
pretty incredible i've never seen it
really
bounce off of such a such a large you
know kind of sudden drop
hey guys what's going on before we
continue with this awesome episode i
want to quickly talk about our sponsor
kraken
for the last 10 years kraken has built
one of the best platforms to buy and
sell cryptocurrencies online
they've got a brand new mobile app the
kraken app today you can go on and buy
bitcoin
or up to 60 of the most popular
cryptocurrencies in the world
and you can do that on the go 24 7.
all you have to do is simply download
the app connect your bank account
and you can get started investing with
as little as 10
it only takes a minute to get started
with the new kraken app you'll have your
portfolio
in your pocket you can track your
portfolio see who the winners and losers
are every day
track your favorite project or just
simply look at the trading volume for
your favorite assets
it has all the features you need without
any of the complexity
it's simply the best place to buy and
sell cryptocurrencies
so go to kraken.com bang bang to learn
more
or go to your favorite app store and
simply search the word kraken and you
can download the mobile app there
kraken's been a longtime supporter of
this show so to say thanks it would mean
the world to me if you would go and
download their new mobile app
all right let's get back into this
episode i hope you're enjoying this one
um you know i want to ask you so you
kind of touched on this how would you
distinguish this between
um you know kind of a mid-cycle
reaccumulation
you know grant we only have two sample
sizes but maybe something like you know
uh mid 2017 mid 2013-ish um or
you know uh heading into a bear market
where like
one of the things you kind of touched on
was the whole short-term holder
long-term holder dynamic where you know
you kind of have this divergence right
now that
the long-term holders are adding like
you touched on and short-term holders
are selling
um you know this has happened four times
in terms of what i've seen maybe maybe
i'm
me correct me here but um you know two
times in during the middle of a cycle
in mid 2013 between the two double pumps
kind of in late 2016
and then um obviously heading into the
you know the two bear markets following
2013
uh bull run and also following the 2017.
so like what what would you be looking
at to um you know kind of distinguish
between
maybe this kind of uh mid cycle
consolidation reaccumulation which is
kind of
where i i kind of stand in that pool but
um you know just for just for listeners
what what kind of things would you be
looking at say okay yeah
uh this is this is resembling uh you
know bear market we're probably heading
into kind of this multi-year bear
so i'm i'm actually uh potentially a bit
left afield here i've
i've more or less in my models dropped
the concept of the cycle um i i almost
don't consider the cycle anymore because
um when you actually start looking at
the supply dynamics uh on chain
i mean ultimately what you're seeing is
the truth right it's the objective truth
sure there's a lot of
volume and stuff going on on exchanges
and off chain but if you then factor in
just what we're seeing on chain
um i mean ultimately a cycle is going to
be driven by a supply squeeze and demand
or lack thereof and what i'm seeing at
the moment is is two things so
we essentially put in a top uh very
similar if you look at the long term
holder supply they started distributing
so we get to this point that i have i
call
peak hotel which is basically the zone
where long term holders own the maximum
amount of supply
and in prior cycles that's pretty much
aligned with when price comes up to the
old
the previous all-time high so back we're
at 20 000 we broke through that
if you look at any long-term holder
supply chart they essentially started
distributing from that point onwards
now there's two things that stand out
the higher the price goes and the larger
you know at a trillion dollar market cap
you just need more dollars to come in
and absorb that supply and we moved very
very quickly from
20 000 to 60 000 really and you just
need an enormous amount of volume to
come in so
where does that volume come in well you
need at that kind of scale you need etfs
you need
sustained buying pressure from
institutions um
you know we saw the grayscale premium
basically drop off a cliff and move into
the discount
so there was a lot of warning signs
telling us that institutions had not
followed through on the swing
and really where we are at the moment is
kind of in this middle ground where
we're waiting for that volume to step in
now
maybe they are the ones accumulating
that's why we're seeing a fairly strong
floor at 30
um maybe there's a lot of buyers down
below but really we need to see that
supply
kick in so um we've very much seen a
distribution by long term holders which
is now actually reversing so you know
arguably the same as previous cycles
um but what you really want to see is um
if you actually look at the amount of
supply held by these these you know
basically let's call them hodlers
the supply held by them in 2017 if i'm
not mistaken was around 60
or 58 of the total supply they currently
hold something on the order of about
75 or 76 so the total floor and there's
more coins circulating since the 2017
top
so by and large long-term holders still
hold a lot more so
the way i'm looking at this is at some
point in the future
there's going to be a supply squeeze
because the trend is pointing in that
direction now when that comes
that's up for the technical analysis and
the very short-term swing trades right
are we in the consolidation do we dip
lower
but right now what i'm seeing is um
hallmarks of what you would otherwise
call a bear market which is long-term
holders accumulating
and not spending but ultimately they're
doing that from a much higher base
they're not doing it from 58 and then
accumulating up to 70
they're accumulating from 70 and if we
get at the same supply squeeze which
occurs at like 80
it's not going to take that long for
that supply squeeze to kick in so
i'm very much looking for are they
spending and are they liquidating
and at the moment the trend is looking
like they are currently accumulating and
holding onto their coins so that that's
really the signal that i'm looking at
that's really fascinating i never
thought about it in terms of kind of
like percentage so
yeah i think that's uh that's really
insightful something i've never
mentioned before um i wanted to ask you
like
what do you think you know the whole um
the futures market plays in all this i
think you know that kind of accelerated
um the moves that we that we saw to the
downside but also i think you know
people like to talk about like oh
leverage is so bad
but you know if it wasn't for the
leverage there would have been those big
spreads
um for you know funds overseas to kind
of capture in that
uh you know kind of market neutral sense
where they were longing spots shorting
the futures i think
um a lot of capital came in on the way
up a you know
through great through the grayscale art
but also through that you know kind of
cash and carry trade arbitrage as well
but you know now that a lot of that
leverage has gotten wiped out do you
think
uh the market is now a lot more driven
by by spot um
and you know how does that kind of
change market dynamics
i do i think we have returned to that
spot driven driven trade uh
i think we had about 60 percent of the
total leverage that we were tracking
uh get wiped out um you know basically
through all of may those two kind of
legs down on the sell-off
we saw almost all of that leverage get
wiped out and
uh what was left that remaining 40 in my
you know
gut feel because that that was fairly
constant it's like a stable floor and
we more or less haven't moved from that
point um that tells me that's
likely to be that risk neutral cash and
carry trade a good chunk of that 40
percent
which didn't care about a 60 drawdown or
a 50 drawdown and
depending on what asset you're looking
at um more or less what i'm seeing there
is that's that's the cash and carry
trade so they're risk mutual they don't
particularly care what's going on
um one thing i will say about so we do
get these cascading liquidations but
you know i think arthur hayes put out an
excellent piece recently on the on the
bitmex blog
where he was talking about how the
crypto markets clear their leverage and
it is just so much more efficient what
we have in traditional markets right
you can have systemic uh risk when these
things flow out and i think this is
something that uh
you know a lot of critics of bitcoin in
this whole market yes we have 100
x leverage um floating around out there
but it settles within an hour
right that gets completely cleared and
flushed and it's all collateralized and
the liquidation engines are just so good
at clearing all of the uh all of the
margin
that all that gets redistributed and the
market then carries on so once the event
has occurred
it then moves into a much more stable
range and yes i do think that we've
moved into a spot driven
uh driven phase um because we're just
not seeing an increase in in leverage
uh we're still seeing relatively neutral
slightly negative funding rates but uh
by and large it's pretty flat so
you know derivatives are not you know
you need a good flush out of all the
speculators they've all lost their money
and now we need to wait for that next
round of people to come in and find
interest again
got it and so check me when you start to
think about um
kind of where we're going from here uh
are there specific milestones
or uh or kind of um you know
specific metrics or anything that you're
looking for you're like
hey if we see x happen uh that's really
gonna tell me something that uh
in either direction really as we've been
going sideways here
um so from this consolidation range i
mean i've kind of mentioned that
we've held that floor despite multiple
capitulations so
that is telling me that there is someone
down there you know
people are accumulating at that range we
are just seeing the supply i mean
um otherwise after a 50 uh drawdown and
pretty much every piece of fud you could
possibly come up with in the market
right we saw
nick carter's fud dice get rolled twice
on on every side
really it's going to take something else
fairly dramatic in my view to really
take out that flaw so
to me it's impressive that we've seen
that floor hold
i'm definitely looking for if those
long-term holders start to find exit
liquidity
right if we do get a relief rally and
they start distributing into that
probably not a great sign i suspect
we'll see some of it i i don't think
that we're going to
you know at some point just rally out of
this consolidation range i think time
and patience is is a big part of this
um but really what i'm looking for is i
look for trends
and you know if if we see long-term
holder supplier really start
distributing if we see
a whole bunch of lifespan metrics start
picking up um you know if we see
exchange balances really resume this
uptrend that we're just seeing people
losing interest and
uh and getting out um you know you can
even look at other signs are we seeing
just a general downtrend in uh
you know the super speculative dogecoins
and and projects that really have driven
on hype and and little else
are we seeing them essentially bleeding
out value and people losing interest
which you know realistically has bear
market dynamics and
you know you need to have this uh this
speculative capital flush out
uh before we can start moving higher so
this is just a typical trend that we see
play out
in these markets yeah and then talk a
little bit just about
um in terms of uh the the trading
versus uh maybe just using this as like
uh
you know education or insights but not
necessarily trading on it uh before we
wrap up i just want to kind of
have you um kind of frame the way you
think about on-chain metrics
uh and kind of where that fits into the
overall market and kind of how you use
that
uh in your pursuit of just better
understanding bitcoin and what's
happening
um is it something that you're trading
with or is it something else
yeah so i think uh this is the
interesting dynamic with on-chain
analysis so because it is so
new there's a number of layers first of
all there's a lot of people still
learning how this stuff works right
so and and to be honest this is the
first let's call it a market cycle this
is the first period of time where we
have
full suites of unchained tools and we've
got numerous analysts you know
glasnode's got a full suite of products
now
and there's there's various analysts who
are all looking at this from different
perspectives
and what we're really doing is
essentially learning as we go
right so what i've definitely found with
on chain is
you want to start big picture and what a
lot of people tend to do is they'll look
at individual metrics and they'll say
that's bullish that's bearish
whereas the way that i look at it is i
on chain is psychology on chain the same
way that a price chart is just human
emotion
fear and greed plotted against time the
way i look at on chain is that same
effect it's the plotting of
fundamentals it's technical analysis of
fundamentals
so you know even on this call and when
i'm writing the newsletter people who
are reading
glasgow's newsletter on the regular
you'll see that i break it down in two
sections i'll focus on miners
right i'll take a particular topic of
interest am i looking at
profit and loss realized on chain am i
looking looking at miners making and
selling are they you know are they
accumulating is
how is their overall performance going
i'll break it down into what is the
psychology of different participants
so when you actually look at it from the
human perspective and you kind of think
a little bit before you start looking at
the chart you think about who are you
actually looking at
and why do you care in particular if
you're looking at long-term holders in
the current instance miners are
obviously a big picture
that's the way i tend to look at things
so um whilst on chain sure there's some
metrics
you can look at the next the next red
and green candle there's some that are
much more high resolution and
you can use in more trading perspective
um what on chain at least it from my
perspective
it really benefits those with the long
it's a macro framework
um there's certainly tools you can dive
down into the weeds and use for
for more um you know day trading type
behavior
but really on chain is absolutely
designed and works
uh immensely well for the long-term
investor for the
the people who are looking for that
long-term trend and once you start
diving in i mean you may have seen that
i kind of break down
um you know what individual uh cohorts
are doing and that gives me insight
right what am i looking for
i'm looking for the old hands getting
their illiquid coins and distributing
distributing them on a on a relief rally
that would be bearish
so it's not so much about you know the
immediate it's really about what's the
trend
and what would it take for that trend to
reverse and change your thesis on are we
getting a supply squeeze
or are we not that's really the way that
i look at things
absolutely makes up makes a ton of sense
it's a very fascinating way to kind of
look at this
um will any last thoughts from you
before we wrap up in terms of uh
what we're seeing in the on-chain
metrics checkmate or anything else
yeah so i just wanted to say um you know
first of all
what check was kind of saying i think
you know on chain is so early
um you know you've had early guys like
obviously like willie david 12
uh you know checkmate these kind of
people who kind of pioneered the space
but now you're starting to see
um you know new people uh younger people
uh you know not just myself but you know
like my buddy dylan he's 20 and he's
digging into the on-chain metrics a lot
right so
i think this this is just getting
started we're just at the tip of the
iceberg in terms of what's going to come
out of this space
um and i think you know as bitcoin
becomes um you know a larger
role in the broader financial system
then the importance of it is just going
to
grow more so and you know check i don't
know how you feel about this but i think
you know as bitcoin kind of becomes a
larger share takes a larger share of
kind of the monetary premium of the
world
on chain will not only you know be used
for kind of driving maybe
maybe maybe trading signals but also
kind of making
um you know assumptions and analyzations
about the economy itself right like
um because at that point you know when
we get to kind of hyper bitcoinization
or whatever you want to call it
um you know you're not only just going
to be looking at this kind of niche
market like we are now but you're
actually going to be
analyzing the the behaviors of you know
people across the economy
um but other than that i just wanted to
say you know thank you to checkmate for
anybody listening
you know checkmate's been one of the
people that has been like very
instrumental and kind of my you know uh
understanding of a lot of this on-chain
stuff um he was somebody i was messaging
like very early on
asking a bunch of questions like you
know i can't
even i feel bad for how many questions
i've asked this guy but he's very
um very useful and if you reach out
he'll you know he's happy to help
a real real genuine guy um i wanted to
give him a chance to kind of plug in
some of the stuff he's working on
checkmate uh does you know a lot of
stuff with glass note obviously
he does the newsletter every week um and
then also he has this website check on
chain so i'll stop talking about what
you kind of plug yourself
in there yeah so i mean glass now we've
got a lot of
a lot of really good initiatives coming
out so obviously we've got our
newsletter which is kind of our flagship
bitcoin uh product primarily and we're
starting to roll out uh
two sides of of video content so the
first one is basically after each week
on chain newsletter
uh the following day we'll have
basically a video read through and the
purpose of that
is people to basically see me live on a
week on chain dashboard which everyone
can get access to
and essentially see how i plug together
multiple metrics and you kind of get the
story behind the text right so
the newsletter we keep it fairly brief
and concise um but you get a little bit
more of my
my thoughts and how i put these things
together and really the intention there
is for more people to understand how
these metrics get put together
um and and really looked as a cohesive
toolkit rather than individual metrics
right there's there is a story to be
told there and that's
really what those those are there to do
we've also got video content coming out
for our
uh glass note academy so that's really
trying to bolster
the actual there's descriptions for
people who are just interested in a high
level view
um so you get a few paragraphs just
understand how the metrics work a video
explainer you know
three five minutes and then there's
sections below that for the real deep
dive analysts who want to understand
what does this look like in a bull
market in a bear market what does a
reversal look like if you're looking for
these real
in deep interpretation uh that's really
what we're rolling out there so
there's a number of educational products
that's really been what's
you know what i'm trying to push forward
um there's a number of exciting ventures
we've got coming out as well you know
things like a
glass node forum um where we're going to
have uh basically chat a zone where
people can actually connect and
basically the uh the inside club where
people can connect with various analysts
share ideas share analysis
um ask questions you know get a bit more
one-on-one access to myself and
all the other unchain analysts at glass
node so
there's a lot in the pipeline uh it's an
exciting time i mean
i i think we're on the cutting edge of
really pushing this space forward in
both on-chain and
just really getting the the pulse of
what bitcoin is doing
and to be honest with the amount that's
gone on since 2020 just in the macro
landscape in the bitcoin landscape what
a great time to be
studying the chain in depth and you know
really understanding the pulse of this
animal
awesome well listen to both of you thank
you guys so much for uh for taking the
time to uh to come on here
um i think that people are really
enjoying this they're learning a ton
um and hopefully we'll continue to do it
and checkmate thanks so much
uh we'll go ahead we'll link to your
stuff uh in the description
um and uh and hopefully we can we can
send some folks over to you and we'll
i will see you again next week my friend
thanks so much palmer thanks again check
you know this this is super fun um
you know i've been following you right
for a long time so great to finally have
you know kind of a
voice-to-voice conversation thanks
chance it's a pleasure